مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
دا
المانيا تكشف عن استراتيجيه جديده للامن
القومي الصين خطيره وشريكه وروسيا اكبر
تعديل
الامير محمد بن سلمان يصل فرنسا في زياره
رسميه يلتقي خلالها ماكرون
ويبحثان عده قضايا
نظام المعاملات المدنيه في السعوديه يرى
النور حمايه للحقوق وفقا للقوانين
العالميه
في الرابعه ايضا
رغم الحرب وصلوا اولى رحلات حجاج السوداني
لميناء جده الاسلامي وعلى متنها
245 حاجا وحاجا
ايقافه معاشات الضمان عن 7300 مستفيد في
السعوديه اعمارهم دون الاربعين رفضوا فرصا
للتوظيف
كشف المستشار الالماني عن استراتيجيه
جديده للامن القومي تركز على امن الطاقه
والصين ووصف استراتيجيات الامن القومي
الالماني الروسيا بانها اكبر تهديد جدي
للنظام الدولي واوروبا كما نصت على ان
روسيا تهدد الديمقراطيه في اوروبا ويجب
التصديلها وشددت الاستراتيجيه الجديده على
ضروره الالتزام بمسار نيتو وتخسيس اثنين
في المئه من الناتجه للانفاق الدفاعي
استراتيجياته الامن القومي الالمانيه
طالبت ايضا بانشاء مركز فيدرالي لمواجهه
الى جامعه الخارجيه بينما حذرت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه من ان الامن في القرن
الحادي والعشرين يعني الا تتجسس الصين على
الهواتف
والعشرين يعني الحصول على الادويه الحيويه
بشكل موثوق في الصيدليه وعدم التجسس من
قبل الصين عند الدردشه مع الاصدقاء او عدم
التلاعب بها من قبل الروبوتات الروسيه عبر
شبكه الاجتماعيه
في تطور لافت اعلن رئيس البيلاروسيه
الكسندر لوكيشنكو ان بلاده بدات تتسلم
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه من روسيا وقال في
تصريحات للاعلام الروسي ان روسيا لم تسعى
الى وضع الصواريخها النوويه في بيلاروسيا
وان منسك هي التي طلبت ذلك اولا وكانت
روسيا وبيلا روسيا اتفقت على نشر صواريخ
اسكندر ام ومقاتلات السوخوي قادره على حمل
القنابل النوويه التكتيكيه
لطالما كنا هدفا لقد ارادوا تمزيقنا الى
اجزاء منذ عام 2020 لكن لم يكن احد في
حاله حرب ضد دوله لديها اسلحه نوويه
لدينا صواريخ وقنابل تلقيناها من روسيا
وكلاهما اقوى بثلاث مرات من تلك التي
اسقطتها الولايات المتحده في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
سينتشر لدينا الكثير من مرافق تخزين
الاسلحه النوويه ولدينا بالفعل الكثير
منها وسوف نستعيد المزيد
ولن نحتفظ بها كلها في مكان واحد
فقد اعتبر ماسس فاجنر بريجوجين طلب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه من المتطوعين توقيع عقود
بانه عار اقترح حلا وسطا يحصل فيه
المتطوعون على ضمانات اجتماعيه ووثائق
ايضا كمشاركين في الاعمال القتاليه
نتابع موضوع اعلان برلين عن استراتيجيه
الامن القومي الالمانيه الجديده ينضم
الينا من باريس العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور
خطاب دكتور خطاب
تخرج من سياساتها المحافظه نحو التوجهات
اكثر تشددا ربما بما كانت
تتضمنه الورقه البيضاء الالمانيه القديمه
احييكم واحيي فريق العمل في العربيه
الرياض وانا مكانه وكل من يتابعنا من
مشاهدات ومشاهدين نعم نحن نعم نحن امام
المانيا جديده وامان ما المانيا قلقه هذا
يظهر من خلال قراءه متانيه
للاستراتيجيه الجديده الاولى للامن الوطني
والتي استغرق اعدادها منذ نوفمبر 2021
اليوم
واتت حرب اوكرانيا لتعطيها زخما اخر
ولتحقق نقله نوعيه في التفكير الاستراتيجي
الالماني الماني ولتحقق نقله نوعيه في
التفكير الاستراتيجي الالماني المانيا لم
تتخلى عن عقده الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بالطبع كانت هي دوما في المعسكر الغربي
كانت دوما في الاطلسي لكنها عندما داهمتها
حرب اوكرانيا اكتشفت
ان جيشها في حاله يرثى لها اكتشفت انها
تعتمد كثيرا بل هي تابعه للطاقه الاتيه من
روسيا اكتشفت ان الصين لها سياسات على ما
يبدو كما تقول المانيا توسعيه اتجاهها
واتجاه الاخرين ولهذا هناك اعاده نظر ضمن
الرؤيه الاطلسيه يعني مثلا هناك
استراتيجيه وطنيه لفرنسا مختلفه بعض الشيء
لا تغالي كثيرا في
في تضخيم الخطر الروسي او الصيني لكن في
الاستراتيجيه الالمانيه ورد بوضوح ان
روسيا تمثل الخطر الاكبر على الامن في
اوروبا والاطلسي اي نحن امام عوده الى
الحرب البارده ونعلم ان خط المانيا
الشرقيه المانيا الغربيه كان اساسيا في
تلك الحرب ونعلم ايضا ان اكبر عداء في
اوروبا عبر التاريخ كان بين المانيا
وروسيا لكن اين
يضعها هذا او هذه الاستراتيجيه الان داخل
الاطلسي كما ذكرت هل يمكن ان يجعلها او هل
نحن امام المانيا تبدو في تصرفاتها
المستقبليه كقائده للاتحاد الاوروبي
نعم هي كما قلت المانيا قلقه ولكن يعني
هناك وضع استراتيجي جديد مع انسحاب
بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني وزن اوروبا المانيا وزن بريطانيا ضمن
الاطلسي او ضمن الحلف الغربي تراجع ولذلك
المانيا تامل ان تاخذ مكان بريطانيا وان
لا تدع فرنسا في موقع قيادي مع ان فرنسا
تمتلك القنبله النوويه تمتلك
امكانيات اكبر عسكريا وهي قلقه لان بولندا
والدول الاخرى من الجبهه الشرقيه للناتو
تحظى الان بدعم امريكي كبير اذا كان
المانيا تستدرك نفسها لكي تلتقط بولندا
والدول المجاوره لها من جهه وتمنع فرنسا
من الصعود في موقف اوروبي مستقل او بناء
قطب استراتيجي مستقل من جهه اخرى اذا نحن
امام لعبه المانيه اقرب ولكنها تتناغم مع
الاستراتيجيه الام ريكيه اكثر فاكثر
يعني فيما يتعلق بالصين تعتبر الصين هي
اهم شريك تجاري لالمانيا بل هي اتجاه
الشريك التجاري الاكبر والاكثر اهميه
لبرلين
من خلال التعبيرات او اللغه التي
استخدمتها في في التعامل مع الصين كيف
يمكن لالمانيا
ان تعمل ضمن خط توازن دقيق او تواجه معضله
التوفيق بين وضع الصين وعلاقتها بها وما
وصفته بها الان من خلال الاستراتيجيه
الجديده التي اعلنت اليوم في برلين
لهذا تكلمت عن التناغم مع الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه
وهنا الموقف من الصين يثير الغرابه
يمثل تحولا كبيرا لانه خلال عهد السيده
مركل الذي دام طويلا هذه المستشاره كانت
تزور الصين مرتين في السنه العلاقات
الروسيه عفوا الصينيه الالمانيه متينه جدا
وكما قلتم متشابكه الان كان المانيا ايضا
قلقه من الصين وكانها تعتمد وجهه النظر
الامريكيه وهكذا ينقسم العالم اكثر فاكثر
نحو شمال وجنوب
وهناك اذا قطبيه ثنائيه ترتسم امامنا
امريكيه صينيه
والمانيا تجد نفسها بدل من ان تكون مع
فرنسا وغيرها قطبا اوروبيا مستقلا يعطي
للتوازنات العالميه قيمه ويمنع الصدام
العالمي
القطيعه اذا اذا ما تم ذلك
نعم على ما يبدو المانيا ايضا تتحول في
هذا الاتجاه
وتعلم جيدا ان الحفاظ على مكانتها
الاقتصاديه ومصالحها التجاريه غير ممكن من
دون المظله الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
والحمايه الامريكيه ولهذا هي تختار معسكر
وتختار صفها في هذا الموضوع نوع من
المغامره بالنسبه للالمان بالنسبه
للاوروبيين لكن عندما يكون هكذا الاستقطاب
حاد الصراع عنيف نحن بدانا مجابهه عالميه
انطلاقا من اوكرانيا ولذلك كل معسكر يحاول
تعزيز صفوفه المانيا تظن انها هكذا ستحفظ
موقعها في العالم علما ان الرؤيه الفرنسيه
تقول ان حفظ اوروبا لموقعها في العالم
يمكن ان يقوم على عدم الانحياز الكامل
لوجهه النظر الامريكيه على بقاء الحلف مع
واشنطن من دون تبعيه واشنطن لكن هذه
الخطوه الالم انيه يعني تقوم بشكل او باخر
بدفن الامال باقامه قطب استراتيجي اوروبي
مستقل شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور خطاب العلاقات
الدوليه من باريس
في زياره هي الثالثه خلال سته اعوام وصل
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس رئاسه
الفرنسيه كشفت عن لقاء يجمع ولي العهد
السعودي بالرئيس الفرنسي منويل ماكرون بعد
غد الجمعه في قصر
سيركز لقاء على العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الرياض وباريس فضلا عن عدد من القضايا
الرئيسيه على راسها الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتداعياتها على بقيه العالم
بحسب بيان الديوان الملكيه السعودي سيلتقي
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان في باريس
الجمعه الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون
وسيشارك في الثاني والعشرين والثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر في قمه تحمل عنوان
نحو ميثاق ماليا عالميا جديد كما سيشارك
قبل ذلك تحديدا يوم الاثنين في حفل
استقبال المملكه الرسمي لترشح الرياض
الاستضافه عام 2030 اما قصر الاليزيف فقد
اوضح ان الرئيس
يستقبل ولي عهد السعوديه على غداء عمل
يناقش خلاله الجانبان قضايا اقليميه
وقضايا دوليه في طليعتها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
والتداعياتها على بقيه العالم كما سيشارك
ولي العهد بحسب الرئاسه الفرنسيه في القمه
الماليه العالميه والهدف منها الجمع بين
التمويل الخاص والتمويل العام وهو ما
تحتاج اليه الارض وشعوبها من اجل مكافحه
الفقر وقياده التحول المناخي والتنوع
البيولوجي بحسب قصر
في الرابعه بعد قليل
استعدادا لموسم حج استثنائي الرابعه والثق
واقع جوده الحياه في مكه المكرمه
اهلا بكم من جديد اقر مجلس الوزراء
السعودي نظام المعاملات المدنيه بعد
استكمال الاجراءات النظاميه لدراسه في
مجلس الشورى يعد النظام نظام المعاملات
المدنيه ثالثه مشروعات منظومه التشريعات
المتخصصه ويشتمل على احكام ايضا تحدد جميع
ما يتعلق بالعقود ياتي نظام ايضا بهدف رفع
كفاءه الانظمه وحمايه الحقوق وتعزيز
الشفافيه كما سيكون مرجعا لتنظيم العلاقه
ايضا بين الافراد في تعاملاتهم وسيحد من
حالات المنازعات بين الافراد فضلا عن
تقليل امد الفصل في الخصومات
[موسيقى]
نعيد التذكير بما قاله الامير محمد بن
سلمان في لقاء الشهير عام 2021 والذي اكد
فيه ان كل القوانين التي تسن في السعوديه
تتماشى مع القران والسنه وتعزز مصالح
الوطن والمواطن وتسن ايضا بناء على
القوانين المتعارفه عليها دوليا
العالم كله يعمل على انظمه واضحه وقمرين
واضحه
لتنظيم حياه البشر احنا دورنا ان كل
القوانين سلف المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تترجم واحد انها لا تخالف القران ولا
القران اللي هو دستورنا لا تخالف مصالحنا
وتعزز مصالحنا تحافظ على امن المواطن
وتحافظ على مصالح المواطن وتساعد في تنميه
ازدهار
الوطن فتسن القوانين بناء على هذا الاجراء
حسب المتعارف عليه دوليا اذا تبغى سايح
يجيك مئه مليون سائح لخلف مليون وظيفه
وتقول انا عندي حاجه جديده اخترعتها
وغير القوانين
لن ياتيك اذا انت تبغى تضاعف مثل ما
ضاعفنا الاستمارات الاجنبيه من خمسه مليار
ريال الى ريال وتقول له تعال استثمر عندي
لكن عندك اختراع جديد
لا محاميه يعرف
الاجراءات التي تعاملها ولا يعرف كيف تطبق
ويحتاج ما يقول لك
الاستثمار في هذه الدوله لما تيجي تستقطب
عقول
وقدرات بشريه للعمل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتقول انا عندي اختراع جديد
لطريقه عمل قوانين القوانين لن ياتيك اي
اي احد فانت
القوانين المتعارف عليها دوليا بناء على
دستورك القران وبناء على مصالحك وبناء على
مستهدفاتك وبناء على حفظ امن ومصالح
المواطن والدفع بتنميه وازدهار الوطن انضم
الينا من الرياض نائب رئيس هيئه الخبراء
في مجلس الوزراء الدكتور عمرو رجب دكتور
عمرو اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
ولن يعني ما هو تعريف المختصر لهذا النظام
النظام المعاملات المدنيه وما هي اهميته
ايضا بالنسبه للمجتمع وكذلك للمستثمرين
مرحبا بدايه يعني اود ان اهنئ القياده
واهنئ مجتمع الاعمال اهم الوطن
والمنظومه القضائيه بصفه عامه المواطن
والمقيم على هذا البلد الطيب
بصدور الموافقه على على هذا النظام والذي
يعني بلا شك ويشكل نقله نوعيه في عمليه
الاصلاح
على جميع المسارات وبالذات فيما يتعلق
بالاصلاح القضائي وتحقيق رؤيه المملكه
النظام طبعا
يتناول هذا النظام وضعت منهجيه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بهذا بمشروع هذا النظام بالنظام هذا
النظام النظام ما في شك يقوم على اسس
ثابته من بدايه اعداده الى حين الى حين
صدوره تتعلق في او شيء مراعاه احكام
الشريعه الاسلاميه
مواكبه المستجدات
والمتطوره والتطورات في الحياه المعاصره
والتزام او الاخذ بافضل
المبادئ والنظريات القانونيه الحديثه
والممارسات القضائيه الدوليه واخيرا
مراعاه الالتزامات او التزامات المملكه في
الاتفاقيات الاتفاقيات التي ترتبط بها
دوليا
النظام المعاملات المدنيه يعني يغطي
جوانب كثيره تتعلق في جميع الجوانب
المتعلقه بالتعاملات المدنيه
في اقسامه
الثلاثه القسم الاول اللي اللي
يتناول بالتفصيل عن احكام المتعلقه
بالتزامات او بالحقوق الخاصه ثم القسم
الثاني المتعلق بالعقود والقسمه الثالثه
المتعلق بالحقوق العينيه وبالتالي هو نظام
شامل يشمل جميع الاحكام ذات العلاقه او
المساس
بالملكيه بحمايه حمايه الملكيه استقرار
العقود وحجياتها منع الاضرار بالغير وما
هي اهم احكام تنظيم العلاقات القانونيه
التي يشتملها النظام بين الافراد
الحقيقه يتناول يتناول جميع جميع المسائل
التي يمكن ان
تتمخر عن اي التزامات
يقوم بها او يرى بالقيام بها الفرد او حتى
على على مستوى سواء الفرد او على مستوى
يعني المستوى المجتمع بشكل عام يعني جميع
الالتزامات المدنيه المتعلقه متعلقه سواء
بالملكيه الخاصه ومتعلقه بالحقوق
والالتزامات
اللصيقه بالشخص الشخص الطبيعي او المعنوي
هذا النظام يعني ينظمها بشكل تفصيلي
ما هو الاثر المتوقع
الحقيقه الاثر اثر اثر جدا عظيم
مثل ما ما جاء في في كلمه
سمو ولي العهد حفظه الله يعني هذا هذا
النظام
يعزز من مبادئ مبادئ كثيره مبادئ موجوده
ولكن هذا هذا النظام سيعزز هذه المبادئ
مثل مبدا الشفافيه مبدا حمايه حمايه
الحقوق
المبدا
القابليه التنبؤ بالاحكام وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاحكام الاحكام الصادره يعني من
القضاء واللي
يعني شوهد ان هناك بعض بعض الشواهد فيما
يتعلق باحيانا اختلاف او تباين الاحكام
فيما يتعلق بالوقائع المتشابهه
هل هو ذات النظام اللي تعمل يعني به دول
اخرى عربيه واجنبيه مثل فرنسا بريطانيا
وغيرها القوانين المدنيه اللي اللي تحكم
العلاقات الفرد والمجتمع بشكل عام
نعم نعم خلاف يعني مسبى النظام النظام
يمكن نظام الانظمه يعني كثير بالنسبه
للتطبيقات
والمرجعيه والدراسات المقارنه اللي وقفت
عليها اللجان وفرق العمل اللي عملت على
على هذا النظام رجعت الى يعني قوانين
مدنيه هو هو يعد هو القانون المدني هو
القانون المدني لكن التسميه قانون نظام
المعاملات المدنيه وله طبعا
تسميات مشابهه في في بعض الدول
استمديناها لن وصل يعني هذا النظام
حقيقه هو خلاصه التجربه تجربه العالميه
سواء تجربه التجارب
الاقليميه او التجارب الدوليه فيما يتعلق
ما يفترض ان يكون في القانون المدني هو
القانون هو الحقيقه هو القانون المدني هو
المظله واضح ولكن القوانين او ما يطلق
عليها القانون المدني في بعض القوانين
المقارنه
سلخت منه ما يتعلق بنظام الاسره ونظام
الاثبات وبالتالي وهذا اللي حصل يعني
المسمى نظام المعاملات المدنيه لان الان
هو هذا ثالث
الانظمه في منظومه التشريعات
المتخصصه اللي بدات في صدور نظام الاحوال
الشخصيه ومن ثم نظام الاثبات وهذا النظام
الثالث ويلحق باذن الله تعالى نظام
العقوبات شكرا جزيلا لك من رياض نائب رئيس
هيئه الخبراء في مجلس الوزراء الدكتور
عمرو رجب
وصلت قبل قليل ولا رحلات حجاج السوداني
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وعلى متنها 245
حاجا وحاجه قادمين من ميناء سواكن من
المتوقع ايضا وصوله سفينه اخرى غدا الخميس
تحمل 1900 حاج من السودان
[موسيقى]
نتابع مع مراسل العربيه نصفيا من الاسلامي
حياك الله هاني مره اخرى ما هي الاجراءات
التي تتم بعد وصول الحجاج السودانيين
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه العربيه العربيه تواكب وصول
الحجاج السودانيين الذين قدموا قبل قرابه
الساعه ونصف هنا الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
لاداء مناسك الحج كنا نقوم بتغطيه مباشره
منذ وصولهم من السفينه وتم وقوف السفينه
الى الرصيف وبعد ذلك انتقالهم الى الصاله
المخصصه لانهاء اجراءات سفرهم وبعد ذلك
الان نقف هنا في الموقف الذي تقف فيه
الحافلات المعدله لهم للصعود اليها وبعد
ذلك سوف تتم عمليه المرحله القادمه وهي
ذهابهم وسفرهم الى المدينه المنوره عبر
هذه الحافلات لدينا هنا خمس حافلات وهي من
الحافلات التي تبقت لمغادره الحجاج
المتبقين وكذلك ايضا نتحدث قبل هذه
الحافلات كانت هناك خدمات ذلك ايضا
اجراءات تم انهائها من قبل الجهات
الحكوميه في السعوديه من وزاره الحج وكذلك
مدير عام للجوازات وايضا وزاره الصحه
السعوديه للتاكد من سلامتهم وايضا وصولهم
مرحبا بك يا حاجه اذا نلتقي بهذه الحاجه
التي وصلت حمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك
مرحب بيك وعليكم السلام كيف كانت الرحله
معك والله الرحله ما شاء الله رحله ممتعه
واتفوجنا تفويج ممتاز جدا حتى وصلنا من
الباخره حتى وصلنا ميناء جده استقبلتنا
البعثه السعوديه بكل ترحاب الحمد لله وعلى
راسها البعثه السودانيه الحمد لله والشكر
لله من خروجكم من ميناء سواكن الى وصولكم
الى ميناء جده شعرتم باي قلق او خوف او
كان الطريق مؤمن كبحري يعني
لا بالعكس الطريق مؤمن بحريا والباخره ما
شاء الله مكتمله السلامه والحمد لله لحدث
ما وصلنا في سلامه وامنه وامان ما شعرنا
باي قلق ولا اي خوف الحمد لله اول ما
وصلتم شاهدتم في فرق طبيه كانت تدخل او
دخلت للتاكد من صحتكم وسلامه
طبيه الحمد لله
وعلى سؤال صحت واحوالنا الحمد لله انت من
اي ولايه انا ولايه كسلا السودان ولايه
كسلا الحمد لله على سلامتك الله يسلمك
الله يكرمك اذا هذه احدى الحاجات التي
الان وصلت وكذلك عدد من الحجاج الذين
نشاهدهم الان ويتم عمليه تنظيمهم وترتيبهم
حتى استعدادا لمغادرتهم الى المدينه
المنوره طبعا سوف يمكثون في المدينه
المنوره بعضهم سوف يغادر عبر هذه الحافلات
التي جهزت وخصصتها لهم السعوديه هناك جزء
اخر ايضا سوف يتم ايضا مغادرتهم عبر قطار
الحرمين هذا القطار الذي سوف يصل الى
المدينه المنوره بشكل سريع وسرعه عاليه
حتى يصلنا بسلامه وامان طبعا بعد ذلك بعد
وصولهم الى المدينه المنوره سوف يعودون
مره اخرى الى مكه المكرمه للبد دخولهم الى
المشاعر المقدسه وكذلك بدء مناسب او بدء
ادائهم لمناسك الحج وايضا توجههم الى
المخيمات التي وفرتها لهم السعوديه
بالتنسيق مع البعثه السودانيه نعم خالد
تفضل شكرا جزيلا لك من ميناء جده الاسلامي
مراسل العربيه
نبقى ايضا في اخبار الحاج حيث يستعد
30,000 جفاني بينهم 8000 سيده للتوجه الى
السعوديه
امين الله عادل وزاهد عادل زوجاني
يانيويان الحج هذا العام يخرجان الى السوق
لاقتناء كل ما يحتاجانه في رحله الحج من
حقائب وملابس الاحرام وغيرها وعند الوداع
يجتمع الاقرباء والاصدقاء في منزلهما ثم
يذهبان الى مجمع الحجاج في كابول لينتظر
الرحيل كنت انتظر هذه الفرصه وانا اشعر
ببالغ السعاده لانني اذهب مع اسرتي
وسنقوم باداء الحج سويا في هذه السنه
فاسال الله ان يتقبل منا ومن جميع هؤلائكه
من يجعله حجا مبرورا
هنا وفي هذا المجمع ينتظران مع غيرهما من
الحجاج الذين يتم حشدهم من المقاطعات
الافغانيه الاخرى ان رحله الحج المباركه
تبدا منذ الخروج من المنزل كما تقول
الحاجه زاهده
انا مسروره ومحدوده جدا بان اتاحت لي فرصه
السفر الى فثواب حج بيت الله عظيم والصلاه
فيه تعادل الاف الصلوات في غيره
من هنا ومن مجمع الحجاج في كابول يتم نقل
الحجاج في هذه الحافلات الى المطار الدولي
بيكابول ليبداوا رحلتهم المباركه بعد
اجراءات في المطار عبر طائرات الكامير
الافغانيه الى الاراضي المقدسه عبد النادر
العربيه
خلال الاعوام الماضيه تتعلق بجوده الحياه
وامسنت المدينه لتلبيه احتياجات الحجج
نواف عزيز يطلعنا على واقع برامج الانسانه
في مكانها
مكه المكرمه اليوم ليست كما كانت عليه قبل
عام 2019 عندما اطلق برنامج خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن ضمن اطار الرؤيه اينما
ذهبت في العاصمه المقدسه ستلاحظ التغيرات
التي احدثها البرنامج
مسطحات خضراء وممرات مشاه ومحطات للحافلات
واحياء مطوره مدعومه باماكن تسوق وترفيه
تلبي احتياجات الحجاج قبل بدء مناسك الحج
وبعدها نحن تفاجانا من اكل من مطاعم من
حتى الاسواق الاوتيلات في فرق كبير
بالنسبه للاكل للمواصلات للخدمه هذا شارع
المسيال المرتبط بساحات المسجد الحرام
انتهت اعمال التطوير فيه قبل ايام مع
استمرار الاعمال التطويريه في الشوارع
المحاذيه له والمخصصه للمشاه
اهلا بكم من جديد اوقفت وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه صرف معاشات
الضمان الاجتماعي لاكثر من 7300 مستفيد في
دفعه الشهر الماضي لاخلالهم بشرط من شروط
صرف المعاش وكشفت مصادر العربيه عن حصول
جميع المستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي
الذين اوقفت الوزاره مع شاتم بسبب ثبوت
عدم جديتهم في البحث عن عمل على ثلاثه فرص
عمل متنوعه رفضوها وفتحت الوزاره باب
الاعتراض لمده شهر ولم يتقدم احد منهم باي
اعتراض
انضم الينا هاتفيا من رياض الدكتور حمد
الحماد الوكيل مساعد للسياسات والتشريعات
في وكاله الضمان الاجتماعي والتمكين حياك
الله دكتور حمد معي في نشره الرابعه اولا
من تفاصيل اضافيه لهذا القرار
حياك الله ارحب فيك اخوي خالد وفي الساده
المشاهدين واجابه على سؤالك فان من اهم
اهداف الضمان الاجتماعي في المملكه تمكين
المستفيدين من تحقيق الاستقلال المالي
والتحول الى شخص منتج من خلال التاهيل
والتدريب وفقا لمنصه على ذلك الماده
الثانيه من نظام الضمان الاجتماعي الصادق
الملكي رقم ميم على 32 لعام 1442 ولذلك
تعمل الوسائل الوزاره تنفيذه للمعامل
المنوطه بها على التعاون مع صندوق تنميه
الموارد البشريه هدف والجهازات العلاقه في
اعداد خطه لكل مستفيد قابل للتاهيل وقادر
على العمل وتقديم خدمات البحث عن العمل
كذلك المتابعه المستمره للمستفيدين
القادرين على العمل للتحقق من مدى تاهيلهم
وايضا مدى جديه القادر على العمل في البحث
عن العمل والذي عروض العمل والتدريب
المناسبه وبناء على ذلك قامت الوزاره
بتقديم خطط وفرص عمل مناسبه
لعدد تستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي استفاد
منها عدد كبير منهم
تجاوز العام
الماضي 100 الف مستفيد الا ان عدد من
المستفيدين القادرين على العمل او
القابلين للتاهيل ومن تم وضع تمكينهم لم
يلتزموا بهذه الخطه التي وضعتها الوزاره
حينها قامت الوزاره بارسال اربع رسائل
خلال فتره امتدت الى اربعه اشهر لحث
المستفيدين على الالتزام بخطه عمل الوزاره
والتقدم في البحث عن العمل واثبات الجديه
وعنده وصول التاكيد على عدم الالتزام
بالاجراءات والسياسات المقرره لدى صندوق
كميه التنميه البشريه هدف لاثبات الجديه
البحث عن العمل تحسم على الوزاره حينها
ايقاف المعاش عن هؤلاء المستفيدين تنفيذه
للفقره الرابعه والخامسه للماده 17 نظام
الضمان الاجتماعي اذا نصت على ان يتوقف
المعاش متى ان المستفيد القادر على العمل
والقابل للتاهيل لم يلتزم بخطه التاهيل او
لم يقبل عروض العمل والتدريب المقدمه لهم
في الوزاره دكتور حمد يعني العدد 7300 شخص
يعني عدد مو بسيط
ابتداء يجب ان نعرف انه بعد قيام المستفيد
بالتسجيل في المنصه واستحقاقه للمعاش تبدا
الوزاره بتقنيه المستفيدين بناء البيانات
والمعلومات المتعلقه بحاله المستفيد
الصحيه مثل البدنيه ايضا كذلك والاجتماعيه
على النحو التالي مستفيد قادر قادر على
العمل ومستفيد قابل للتاهيل ومستفيد غير
قابل للتاهيل ونقصد بغير القابل للتاهيل
هي الحالات التي لا يمكن ان تمارس اي من
الاعمال التي تساهم في تحويل المستفيد الى
شخص منتج ومستقل ماليا مثل كبار السن او
المعاق اعاقه جعلت من شخص غير قادر على
العمل وبعد ذلك لتحقيق اهداف الضمان
الاجتماعي يطلب من
المستفيد
وتاهيل وعند عدم وجود هديه المستفيد في
الالتزام بالخطه حينها يتم ايقاف صرف
المعاش له تنفيدا للفقره الرابعه والخامسه
من الماده السابعه عشر من النظام الضمان
الاجتماعي والوزاره تتحقق من ثبوت عدم
جديه في البحث عن العمل وفق لما يرد اليها
من صندوق تلميذ التنميه البشريه هدف بناء
الاجراءات والسياسات المقرره هناك مثل
[موسيقى]
في منصه الموحده للتوظيف
والموافقه عليها والاقرار على الالتزامات
الوارده فيها وبالمناسبه جميع من تم ايقاف
الصوت عنهم هم من اخلوا بهذه الفقره فلم
يقوموا في المنصه الموحده للتوظيف ايضا من
الاجراءات والسياسات الوارده لدى صندوق
التنميه البشريه هدف عدم التجاوب التواصل
مع التنميه البشريه اكثر من ثلاث مرات او
التخلف عن الحضور المقابل الوظيفيه اللي
ثلاث مرات او عدم قبول الفرص الوظيفيه
المعروضه للمستفيد لمده ثلاث مرات بس يمكن
فرص المقدمه اصلا او الموجوده تلائم
المستفيده وما تلائم ظروف وربما هنا في
هذه الحاله التي تكونون فيها يعني
صحيح هو يعني مثل ما سبق انفا النظام يسعى
الى تحويل مستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي
والقابلين للتاهيل من اشخاص متلقين للدعم
الاجتماعي الى افراد منتجين ومستقلين
ماليين عبر خدمات التاهيل والتمكين لان
الاصل في القاطع الامل هو ان يعمل ولذلك
تقدم الوزاره للمستفيدين ما يتوفر للق
طاع الخاص كل مستفيد على حده وتجدر
الاشاره الى ان المتطلبات من المستفيدين
تكون على حالتين الحاله الاولى اثبات
الجديه في البحث عن العمل وذلك
مثل في دراسه صندوق كلمه الموارد البشريه
في طاقات الحاله الثانيه هي قبول الفرص
الوظيفيه التي تقدمها الوزاره المستثمرين
بخلال شركائها بعد قيام الوزاره بدراسه
المؤهله المستفيدين
ومطابقتها ومعرفه مدى مناسبه هذه الفرص
للمتقدم باعتذارات تقبلها الوزاره علما
بان الوزاره تقدم ثلاث فرص وظيفيه لهؤلاء
المستفيدين وتتحرر الوزاره ان تكون هذه
الثلاث فرص الوظيفيه كلها مناسبه مع هذا
المستفيد ومؤهلات
وهي
ان الفيتقدمها الوزاره للمستفيدين هي اعلى
من الحد الادنى للاجور وبالتالي فهي
بطبيعه الحال اعلى من مبلغ الدعم المقدم
لمستفيد في الضمان الاجتماعي شكرا لك
يعطيك العافيه الدكتور محمد الحماد الوكيل
مساعد للسياسات والتشريعات في وكاله
الضمان الاجتماعي والتمكين
احبطت دائره الجمارك الملكيه الماليزيه
محاوله التهريب
302 كلغ من ماده الكوكايين المخدر وتم
اكتشافها بعد التعاون وزاره الداخليه
السعوديه مع نظيرتها الماليزيه في رصد
الماده التي كانت مخبئه في فول الصويا
داخل حاويه قادمه من احد الدول جاء ذلك
بعد التقديم معلومات بين البلدين ومتابعه
ضبط المواد والانشطه الاجراميه التي
تستهدف امن المملكه
مجلس الوزراء السعوديه على الترتيبات
التنظيميه لتحويل الهيئه السعوديه للفضائل
وكاله الفضاء السعوديه لتمثل نقله نوعيه
من حيث التركيز على صناعه سوق الفضاء واكد
رئيس مجلس اداره وكاله الفضاء السعوديه
المهندس عبدالله السواحه ان موافقه مجلس
الوزراء على الترتيبات التنظيميه لتحويل
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء الى وكاله الفضاء
السعوديه تمثل نقله نوعيه من حيث التركيز
على صناعه سوق الفضاء وتحفيز البحث
والابتكار فيه
المجموعه الشمسيه وافرادها تقاس
بالكيلومتر اما النجوم فتقاس بالسنين
الضوئيه خالد الزعل
[موسيقى]
اصوات واشكال البشر على شاشات التلفزه
والاجهزه الذكيه هي تحاكي الحقيقه وليست
الحقيقه ذاتها وهذا حالنا مع نجوم السماء
فمن النجوم من مات ولا وجود له وما زلنا
نشاهد ماضيها الان ومن النجوم من ولد
وموجود لكن لا نشاهده الان لان خبر ولادته
لم يصلنا حتى الان ليش لان النجوم تبعد
عنا بعدا سحيقا وهذه المسافات لا تقاس
بالكيلو مترات انما تقاس بالسنين الضوئيه
والسنه الضوئيه الواحده هي المسافه التي
يقطعها الضوء في سنه وهو يسير بسرعه 300
الف كيلو متر بثانيه ان مواقعها عظيمه فلا
اقسم بمواقع النجوم وانه لقسم لو تعلمون
عظيم
[تصفيق]
فالمجموعه الشمسيه وافرادها من الزهره الى
نبت تقاس بالكيلو مترات فالشمس تبعد عنا
150 مليون كيلو متر وضوءها يصلنا بعد ثمان
دقائق تقريبا اما النجوم فلها حكايه
مغايره فاقرب نجم لنا يبعد عنا اربع سنوات
ونصف سنه ضوئيه وش يعني هالكلام هذا يعني
ان هذا النجم لو انفجر ما رايح ندريبه الا
بعد اربع سنوات ان يعتقر صغرا فربما مفخما
يبدو ضئيل شخصي للنظاري ان الكواكب في علو
محلها لا ترى صغارا وهي
غير صغاري
[موسيقى]
ا
المانيا تكشف عن استراتيجيه جديده للامن
القومي الصين خطيره وشريكه وروسيا اكبر
تهديد
الامير محمد بن سلمان يصل فرنسا في زياره
رسميه يلتقي خلالها ماكرون ويبحثان عده
قضايا
نظام المعاملات المدنيه في السعوديه يرى
النور حمايه للحقوق وفق القوانين العالميه
رغم الحرب اصول اولى رحلات حجج السودان
الى ميناء جده الاسلاميه على متنها 245
خارجا
وايقافه معاشات الضمان على 7300 مستفيد في
السعوديه اعماره دون الاربعين ورفضوا فرص
التوقيف
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات